all right and idaho is luis hi Luis how
are you good how are you better than I
deserve what's up hey I got a real
simple question uh my wife and I are
fairly new to the program but I had some
family the other day talking about how
foolish it was not to have a credit card
because then if we'd ever want to buy a
house or something take out a mortgage
that we would have no credit no and I
remember I heard you talk about it
before I just want to be able to explain
to them that it they say it's impossible
to take out a mortgage without a credit
score well that's just somebody that
doesn't know what they're talking about
I'm sure they're broke people but there
in your family we all got people like
that in our family that are experts on
something that they don't know nothing
about so if you go to churchill mortgage
or other mortgage brokers that actually
know how to do what's called manual
underwriting where they don't require a
credit score but they do require that
they verify your job and they verify
your down payment is in the actual bank
and they do what's manually underwrite
it instead of just depending on the
credit score to give you the loan then
you can get a you can get a mortgage
loan at no extra charge no extra thing
at all no problems at all except it's a
little bit more hassle to do manual
underwriting and so it's done every day
Churchill's done it for years we thought
we've told people to do this for years
they do it all the time you know if
you're self-employed you have to have
two years of tax returns and if you're
self-employed you can't get an FHA loan
now or you have you know so there's some
of these loans they just won't write
them but but other than that you know
it's it's a very normal process it's
kind of how mortgage is used to be done
before the FICO score like when I got my
real estate license in the 70s it's how
we used to do mortgages you actually had
to go in and prove you had an income and
a job and you had to prove you know that
you pay your bills on time they pulled a
copy of your credit bureau and looked at
your past even if there was no credit
score there's stuff on your credit
bureau from your past but if you have no
open accounts for six months to a year
no open accounts with no balances
kind then eventually you're gonna have
no credit score which is what I have I
have not a credit score in 20 years -
zero
and it's working out for me pretty good
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey you
guys Rachael Cruz here hope you are
enjoying the Dave Ramsey show and did
you know that I have my very own YouTube
channel yes that's right it's kind of
better than the Dave Ramsey channel
don't tell them I said that I'm kidding
I'm kidding
so subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
you can check out how to do a monthly
budget it's one of the best videos out
there
you